Я з такими цікавими новинами колеги
вчора мені стало відомо що одна
славнозвісна депутатка безугла яка До
речі керує під комітетом в комітеті
нацбобони який займався в тому числі
реформуванням СБУ Після того як я
прокоментувала її пост подала заяву в
СБУ відносно мене Та ще декількох
волонтерів стверджуючи що ми здійснили
на неї атаку і тому вона хоче щоб в СБУ
перевірили наші зв'язки знаєте наші
зв'язки очевидні ми ті люди які з 14-го
року робимо все для перемоги для нашої
країни Ми добровольці волонтери меценати
благодійники пані безугла якщо ви дійсно
зареєстрували дану заяву а проти
волонтерів в СБУ облікують опублікуйте
її тоді ми всі разом сходимо на
одночасні допити і тоді будуть готові і
тоді ви будьте готові своє пусто слів’я
підтвердити підписом у протоколі А я з
свого боку разом з захисниками подам
заяву про завідуме неправдиві покази і
буду себе захищати адже коли
представники влади коли представник
влади використовує державний ресурс
політичній боротьбі навантажуючи СБУ у
воєнний час своїми вигадками то це повна
дурниця і нагадує коли будь-хто волонтер
цивільна особа депутат критикує Владу і
реагує на її неадекватну поведінку вона
це все називає мережею яка здійснює на
її думку якоїсь злочинну діяльність
показує наскільки вона є подібною на
псевдодепутатів Росії І через неї я
замість того щоб займатися пораненими
буду зайнята допитами в СБУ А тепер
відносно мене Можливо хтось з вас мало
що про мене знає мені нещодавно
виповнилося 27 років і все життя
починаючи з 18 років Я присвячую
порятунку людей о 14-му році
Дякую у 14-му році одразу після школи я
вирішила добровольцем на фронт 90 але на
собі вивозили і змогла вивезти понад 200
поранених бійців я це би далі
продовжувала якби на жаль не сталась моя
цивільна травма але навіть після
інвалідності я продовжила рятувати життя
разом зі своїми госпітальєрами я не
залишила свій підрозділ і продовжувала
робити все для того щоб врятувати
Якомога більше людей за ці роки я
здобула таку репутацію що в 23 роки я
балотувалася в Верховну Раду була
обраною
мене там мій підрозділ знають та шанують
сотні тисяч людей і я щодня кладу своє
життя і здоров'я заради нашої Перемоги
Шкода що є депутати які займаються іншим
на останок Хочу додати важливі тези про
роботу нашої фракції яка постійно
знецінюється наша фракція європейська
Солідарність всі місяці перед початком
повномасштабної війни кричала про те що
треба збільшувати армію готувати
бомбосховища проводити просвітницьку
роботу серед цивільних та ще безліч чого
натомість ви всі казали що ми із старим
що ми це використовуємо в якихось своїх
політичних іграх через Це ваші спікери
щодня на ефірах та в соцмережах знаючи
правду обманювали Я особисто мала багато
ефірів де Мала суперечки завершилася